Vladimir Putin is talking tough is
in a speech on September 21st he gave
the world a glimpse of what Russia's
next move might be
the economist's defense editor Shashank
Joshi and Russia editor Arcadia
ostrovsky talk through three key
takeaways from Putin's speech
thank you
immobilization
this is the most unpopular decision that
President Putin has probably taken in
many years in power possibly since the
beginning of his presidency Vladimir
Putin is now belatedly mobilizing
reservists in theory three hundred
thousand men with prior military service
but there's no guarantee that it stops
at 300 000 men there's already some
indication that the Kremlin may want to
recruit many times more than that
hundreds of people mostly young came out
in the streets across Russia in some 30
cities some of them as a punishment for
those protests have been served draft
papers to take them to the front there
are very few willing to go this is a
major political crisis in the middle of
a war
foreign
language can be very deceptive
particularly in Russia this is not real
referendence uh this is part of Putin's
performance to enact some territory in
the southeast of Ukraine there is no
legal provision for it uh it's
completely illegal what he is trying to
do is to signal to the West that he is
prepared to escalate and not prepared to
lose the logic his logic that is goes
something like this if this are the
territories of the Russian Federation
then Russian nuclear umbrella extends to
them
foreign
Russia has many many thousands of
nuclear weapons but most of these are
strategic weapons designed to destroy
cities what the world has become more
concerned about in recent weeks is
Russia's arsenal of what we call
non-strategic or sometimes tactical
nuclear weapons the worry is that Putin
might use one of these smaller nuclear
weapons to psychologically shock Ukraine
or its Western allies into capitulation
or negotiation it is of course
impossible to say what's inside Putin's
head this is serious weapons and it's a
serious threat
the Western Powers the American the
Allies have made it very clear to Putin
that this black male will not be
tolerated and in case of his use
of nuclear arms of any kind there will
be a very strong response
to read more of our coverage on the war
in Ukraine and the events in Russia
please click on the link
and thank you for watching don't forget
to subscribe